Third is unilaterally by the will of the
wife. If it is mentioned in the marital
contract, it's known asma or talid that
if she writes in the marital contract
that even she if she wishes she can give
a divorce and if the husband agrees
during the marital contract then even
she can give unital divorce. The fourth
is that if it's not mentioned in the
marital contract that the wife can give
relal divorce but if the husband ill
tweets her or doesn't give her due
rights she can very well go to the kazi
to the chief judge and take a nikai fusk
nullification of the marriage and the
last is that even the husband is good
but if the wife wants to part away she
can request the husband to give divorce
it's known as kola basically or broadly
there are five types first by mutual
consent of both husband and wife. Second
by unital will of the husband. Third by
unital will of the wife if it's
mentioned in the marital contract.
Fourth is if the husband ill treats she
can do nikay fusk. And fifth that even
if the husband is good and if for
personal reason she wants to part she
can take kah. Let's analyze the family
values of the parents concerning parents
in Islam that's father and mother. Next
to worship of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
Allah says in the glorious Quran in
surah Isra chapter number 17 verse
number 23 and 24 that I have ordained
for you that you worship none but Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala and that you respect
your parents and if anyone or both of
them reach old age do not say a word of
contempt don't even say off to them
but lower to them your wing of humility
and address them with honor and pray to
the Lord that bless them as they
cherished me in childhood. Means even if
your parents get old, you cannot say a
word of contempt. You can't even do to
them.
The Quran says in surah chapter 6 verse
151 that be good to your parents. The
Quran says in surah um 31 verse number
14 that we have enjoined on the human
beings to be kind to the parents. In
trivial upon trivial did your mother
bore you and in years twain was your
weaning. The Quran says in surk chapter
number 46 verse number 15 we have
enjoined on the human beings to be good
to their parents in pain did the mother
b you and pain did she give you birth.
Our beloved prophet said it's mentioned
in maja as well as the hadith of Ahmed
that paradise lies beneath the feet of
your mother.
That doesn't mean that if my mother is
walking on muk and filth that thing
becomes paradise. What it means that if
you love your mother, if you respect
your mother, if you're good to your
mother, you will inshallah God willing
go to paradise.
And a prophet said it's mentioned in say
bkari volume number 8 in the book of
adab book of manners chapter number two
hadith number two that a man came to the
prophet and asked him that who deserves
the maximum
love and companionship in this world and
the prophet said your mother the man
asked who's next the prophet said your
mother the man asked the third time
who's next and the prophet said your
mother the man asked after that Then the
prophet said your father. That means
when it comes to love and companionship
to the parents according to the hadith
of a beloved prophet 75% goes to the
mother. 25% goes to the father. 3/4 goes
to the mother and 1/4 goes to the
father. In short the mother gets the
gold medal, she gets the silver medal as
well as the bronze medal. The father has
to be satisfied with the mere
consolation prize.
In Islam, after a person dies, the
inheritance is given in the family
according to the laws laid down by Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala which is mentioned
in surah nisa chapter number four verse
number 11 and 12 that as to the
inheritance of children
the males they get double the share of
the female that mean the son gets double
the share of the daughter. If only one
daughter she gets half. If two or more
they share in a 2/3 as to the parents
each get one sixth.
If no children then the mother gets
one/3 after paying off the debts. Verse
number 12 versis says as in what your
wives leave for you. You get a half if
there are no children. You get a quarter
if there are children. As for what you
leave for your wives, your wives get 1/4
if there are no children and 1/8 if
there are children. And there are people
who take objection that you know why do
the women always inherit half the share
of the men in the family. That's not
always true. As I mentioned where it
comes to parents both get equal. If
there are children and if there are no
children and if suppose there is a lady
who dies and she has no children then
the husband gets half the father gets
one sixth and the mother gets one/3.
That means the mother inherits double
that of the father. the mother inherits
double than that of the father. So there
are cases in which women do get double
also. But I do agree in most of the
cases they get half. And the reason is
that since the financial burden is laid
on the shoulder of the man in Islam,
Almighty God does not want to put an
extra burden on the male. For example,
if after giving the shares of a person
who has died, a person dies and after
giving the shares to all the relatives,
suppose £150,000 are remaining for the
children and he has one son and one
daughter, the son will get £100,000 and
the daughter will get £50,000. But would
you prefer inheriting £100,000 and
spending maybe 80 or 90,000 on your
family and on your relatives or would
you prefer inheriting £50,000 and
keeping all for yourself? You need not
even spend a single pound on your
clothing. That the duty of the man in
the family. So but natural even in
inheritance the woman actually overall
is on a much better level. I would like
to end my talk by giving the quotation
of the glorious Quran from surah is
chapter number four verse number 135
that
oh you believe stand out firmly for
justice.
Stand out firmly for justice as witness
to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala even if it
be against yourself against your parents
against your relatives against your kit
and kin or rich and poor for Allah
protects all where it comes to giving
witness to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
obedience to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
he's on the highest level even if it has
to go against yourself you should go
even against your parents against your
relatives because worship of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is the highest in
Islam alhamdulillah Alami.
Thank you very much indeed, Dr. Nick.
I've, as I said, I've not heard him
before, but I certainly look out for his
tapes and, uh, look into his talks a bit
further. Thank you very much indeed.
Just a few logistical points. Um, the
question and answer session, um, we've
actually scheduled to start at 10:00,
but the way things are going, we may
actually be able to start a bit earlier
than that, which case we'll finish a bit
earlier. There will be no, uh, questions
from the floor. Questions have to be
written. So anybody if you want to
there's paper on all the seats if you
want to submit some questions there are
some brothers from the young Muslims who
will be wandering up and down the sides
of the hall if you could just pass them
to them and we'll select the questions
that uh we'll try and answer later on
now I'd like to ask William Taylor to
come and give his comments. Thank you.
Uh thank you very much Dr. Zakir. uh for
me it was fascinating to hear this uh
joint analysis of the task which faces
us uh in our society. I'm speaking now
about Britain but as Christians and
Muslims together um I simply draw out of
Dr. Zakia's address uh two things he
identified as a major problem within our
own society. Firstly, divorce. As you
may know, Britain has the highest rate
of divorce in Europe and the
disintegration of the family. Uh this is
a task which faces both uh religions and
which we can address together and I hope
there will be a forum for this. I've
just come back from Egypt and I've been
in one of the Egyptian Coptic
monasteries and a phrase which was used
by Anthony of Egypt who founded the
Egyptian monastic way of life has come
to haunt me and it's this one he said
your life and your death are with your
neighbor and this is speaking about the
cohesive role of religious faith in
defining a relig society's values is and
I'd like to draw on several of the
points about godlessness because this is
the situation which faces us all in
liberal western societies and it is that
absence of the ultimate and transcendent
authority of which he spoke which uh is
the common problem uh facing us and all
the human behavioral problems which stem
out of that and submission um with the
with the fruits he uh he drew are common
to all of us and I do hope that the
common analysis of the as it were
societal failure which faces us will be
a cause for cooperation between our two
faiths in the future and especially that
uh analysis of the pre-Islamic society
in Arabia um with its senseless violence
and lack of meaning and so on startling
parallels with our own times
So, thank you very much for both those
analyses. Thank you.
Fine. Thank you very much. Just a
reminder, if you want to ask any
questions, please write them down and
pass them along to any of the brothers
walking along the sides and then we'll
try and answer as many of those as
possible. Can I ask uh Reverend Taylor
actually to start because he actually
needs to get away. So perhaps if we can
get him uh to come, he's got the
questions in front of him. So try and
answer as many as you can in the next 10
minutes or so. It's just that he needs
to get away. Okay.
Well, thank you very much uh whoever
sent me the uh three questions on
homosexuality.
Uh I'd like to approach this subject by
speaking about the uh biblical view and
the view in Christian tradition of
sexual activity because sexual activity
in the view of the Bible and the
Christian tradition is reserved for the
married state. That's the first thing to
make very clear that sexual activity is
to be confined within marriage. Any
sexual activity outside marriage is
described as sin in the Bible and in
Christian tradition. So I would put uh
homosexuality, the Christian tradition
puts homosexuality uh firmly in that
context as sexual activity outside
marriage and is described in the uh
biblical and Christian tradition as a
sin.
The next uh question is does the Bible
prophesy the advent of prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him? Um the answer is
that's a very difficult question to
answer and it's not clear. Um my own um
perspective from the biblical evidence
itself is that the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him is not prophesied
within the text of scripture. Um but I
know that Muslims would take a different
view. Uh and similarly uh a similar
question is where do you place the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him? Um I
I like other Christians uh revere and
respect the uh prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and the Muslim tradition as the
aal kitav the people of the book uh
Jews, Christians and Muslims share our
common Abrahamic faith and uh and that's
where I I I would place that and
certainly within my own experience of
working in the dasis of Jerusalem
Palestinian dasis have had the closest
cooperation with uh Muslims and
Christians in that city in particular
resisting Israeli occupation. But that's
that's getting me into another area. Um
I'd like to move on now to other
questions.
What is the status and position of Jesus
in Islam and in Christianity?
Islam is the only non-Christian faith
which makes an article of faith to
believe in Jesus peace be upon him. No
Muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus peace be upon him. We
believe that he was one of the mightiest
messengers of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
We believe that he was born miraculously
without any male intervention. We
believe that he gave life to the dead
with God's permission. We believe that
he healed those born blind and lepers
with God's permission. The Muslims and
Christians we are going together but
there are parting of phase. There are
many of our Christian brothers and
sisters who say that Jesus peace be upon
him he claimed divinity. He claimed that
he was God. In fact if you read the
Bible there is no unequivocal statement
in the complete Bible where Jesus peace
be upon himself says that I'm God or
where he says worship me. There is not a
single unequivocal statement in the
complete Bible where Jesus peace be upon
himself says he's God or where he says
worship me. In fact, if you read the
Bible, Jesus peace be upon himself says
it's mentioned in the gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number 28, my
father is greater than I. In the Gospel
of John chapter number 10 verse number
29, my father is greater than all. In
the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 12
verse number 28, I cast out devils with
the spirit of God. Gospel of Luke
chapter number 11 verse number 20. I
with the finger of God cast out devils.
Gospel of John chapter number 5 verse
number 30. I can of my own self do
nothing. As I hear I judge and my
judgment is just. For I seek not my will
but the will of my father. Not my will
but the will of Almighty God. If you
translate into Arabic it's Islam. And
anyone who says not my will but God's
will, he's a Muslim. As the Quran says
in surah al Imran chapter 3 verse 52
that is Alisam was a Muslim. He never
said he was God. In fact he said he was
sent by God. He said in Gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number 24. The
words you hear are not mine but my
fathers who have sent me. Gospel of John
chapter number 17 verse number three.
This is life eternal so that you may
believe in one true God and Jesus Christ
whom thou has sent. mentioned in the
Gospel of Acts chapter number 2 verse
number 22 that here O Israel Jesus of
Nazareth a man approved of God amongst
you by wonders and miracles which God
did by him and you were witness to it he
never claimed divinity Bible says a man
approved of God by wonders and miracles
which God did by him and when he was
asked the question which is the first of
the commandment Jesus peace be upon him
said in the gospel of Mark chapter
number 12:29 in Hebrew
The hero Israel the god our lord is one
god
can you compare the dress code hijab
between Islam and Christianity regarding
the hijab of Islam people talk about
hijab for women but Allah subhananaa's
glorious Quran first speaks about the
hijab for man it's mentioned in surah
nur chapter 24 verse number 30 that say
to the believing man that he should
lower his gaze and guard his modesty
moment he looks at a woman and any
brazen thought comes in his he should
lower his case. There was a friend of
mine who was staring at a girl who was
Muslim friend told him why are you
staring for such a long time. So he told
me a prophet said the first dance is
allowed the second is prohibited. I have
not completed half my glance.
What did the prophet mean the first
glance allowed? What he meant that if
you unknowingly unintentionally look at
a woman don't intentionally look at her
again. That doesn't mean you can look at
a woman for 10 minutes without blinking
and saying I have not complete my
glance. And a similar message is given
in the Bible in the gospel of Matthew
chapter number 5 verse number 27:28.
Jesus peace be upon him says it has been
said of the old times thou shalt not
commit adultery but I say unto you
whosoever lookth at a woman to lust
after her has already committed adultery
in his heart.
Next the Quran speaks about the hijab
for the woman in surah N 24 verse number
31 that say to the believing woman that
she should lower her gaze and guard her
modesty and draw her well over the bosom
and dispel on a beauty except for
appears ordinarily of except in front of
a husband her father or her sons and a
big list of marams or close relatives is
given and there are basically six
criterias for hijab. The first is for
the man nl to the knee is extent for the
woman the complete body should be
covered the only part that can be seen
are the face and the hands up to the
wrist. Second and the remaining five are
the same for the men and women. Second
is the clothes they wear should not be
so tight that it reveals the figure.
Third, it should not be transparent so
that we can see through. Fourth, it
should not be glamorous where it
attracts the opposite sex. Fifth, it
should not resemble that of the opposite
sex. And last, it should not resemble
that of the unbeliever. And the reason
for hijab is given in surahab 33:59 that
oh prophet tell your wives and the
believing women that when they go abroad
they should put on the cloak so that
they shall be recognized and it will
prevent them from being molested. Hijab
has been prescribed for the women so
that it will prevent them from being
molested. Suppose there are two twin
sisters who are equally beautiful who
are walking down the streets of London.
One is wearing the Islamic hijab,
complete body covered except the face
and the hands up to the wrist and the
other twin sisters wearing the skirt of
the short mini the western clothes and
they're walking down the streets
together and around the corner there is
a hooligan. There's a ruffian waiting
for a catch. Which girl will it tease?
Will it tease the girl wearing the
Islamic hijab or will it tease the girl
wearing the skirt of the mini? Which
girl will it tease? The girl wearing the
skirt of the mini. It's but natural.
Quran rightly says hijab has been
prescribed to prevent the woman from
being molested. And a similar message is
given in the Bible. If you read in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 22
verse number 5, the woman shall not wear
clothes that which pertinent to a man
and a man shall not wear clothes that
which pertinent to a woman. It's
mentioned in the 1 Timothy chapter
number 2 verse number 9 that the woman
should be dressed up with modesty with
shamef facedness and sobriety. They
should not wear costly array and braided
hair of gold and they should not wear
expensive array. So if you compare the
dress code in the Bible and the Quran
the same how was mother Mary may Allah
be pleased with how was she dressed up.
If you have seen a photograph just like
how Muslim woman should be dressed up.
So if you read the scriptures not going
on what the followers do. If you read
the scripture the dress code of Islam
and Christianity is the same. Is not
Islam ruthless as it has permitted
chopping of hands for theft whereas
Christianity is a religion of love and
mercy. There is a reference to the Quran
of this what the brother is referring to
that there's a quotation in surah Maida
chapter number 5 verse number 30 which
says that as to the thief be it a man or
a woman chop of his or her hand as a
punishment from Allah subhana wa t'ala
in Islam there is a philosophy that you
should not rob same as then Christianity
but Islam besides telling not to rob it
shows you a way how to achieve that
state in which people will not rob Islam
has a system of zakat that's every rich
person who has a saving of more than the
nissab will he or she should give 2.5%
of that saving every lunar year in
charity and it is the duty of the state
to look after the people that they are
properly fed etc and if after that
anyone robs the Islamic Sharia says
Quran surah maida ch 5 verse number 38
that as to the thief beat a man or woman
chop of his or her hand as a punishment
from Allah subhana wa t'ala people may
say it's a ruthless law it's a merciless
law I'm asking the question that today
America which happens to be one of the
most advanced country in the world.
Unfortunately, he also has one of the
highest rates of crime. If you implement
the Islamic share in America that every
man he should give zakat who's rich 2.5%
of the Texas saving charity and the
state should look after the people and
after that if anyone robs chop of his or
her hand as a punishment. I'm asking the
question will the rate of robbery will
it increase? Will it remain the same or
will it decrease in America? What will
happen? It will decrease. It's a
practical law. You implement the Sharia
regarding Christianity is a merciful
religion. Yes, it speaks about God as
merciful. Even Quran, every chapter
begins with the statement
in the name of Allah, most gracious,
most merciful. There is even a reference
in the Bible regarding chopping of the
hand. For people who don't know, if you
read the book of Deuteronomy chapter
number 25 verse number 11 and 12, it
says that if two men are striving
against each other, fighting against
each other, and if the wife of one of
the husbands who's being defeated by the
man, if she helps the husband in
overpowering the man who's fighting him
and holds him by the secrets, that's the
private part. The Bible says in verse
number 12, chop off her hand and the
eyes shall show no mercy. So even the
Bible has chopping of the hands. If the
wife helps the husband, if someone is
trying to overpower him, the Bible says
chopping of the hands. Deuteronomy 25
verse number 11 and 12. And Islam is a
merciful religion as well as just. It
sees to it that it does justice between
both. The person committing the crime,
if the punishment is still, he will not
commit again. And the person on whom
crime is committed, Allah sees to it
that mercy is done on both.
afterwards
in after they'll answer the other
question.
Reverend Taylor actually has to go and
pick up his mother from the station. So,
I'm going to actually ask him to come
and um answer. He's got loads of
questions. He won't have time to answer
perhaps more than two or three. Uh and
then I'd like to thank him very much for
coming and helping us at this meeting.
Thank you, dear Reverend.
Well, I think um looking doing my duty
as a son, I have to collect my mother
from Houston station, which should take
me straight to paradise as I'm looking
after my mother. Family values. I've
Thank you to all of you who've sent uh
questions to me. They're all very
important questions. I wish I had the
time to answer them all. Um but I'm
going to focus on three of them uh
because they um deal with different
areas. First one is a factual one which
I'd like to address straight away and
it's this um why is it that the Bible is
now recorded in the Greek text when
Jesus's original language was Aramaic?
Please explain. The reason for this is
that the New Testament documents were
written in Greek but also in Aramaic and
Syriak which is the the Christian
dialect of Aramaic as it were to reach a
maximum audience. uh Aramaic was more
restricted to the Near East. And if you
wanted to communicate with the wider
Roman Empire throughout the
Mediterranean, then Greek would be the
language you would use to uh to do that.
But of course, there are phrases in the
Gospels preserved in Aramaic,
Talithakumi, Elohi,
and phrases like this which were used by
Jesus and preserved in the Gospels. Um
the next one is an important one
politically uh because it speaks about
Kosovo. Um the question is this what the
Christian world and civilized west is
doing today to stop another genocide in
Kosovo similar to that of Bosnia. Well I
would I want want to draw parallel here
with Iraq and to immediately um squash
the suggestion as it were that this is
the Christian world. I would talk about
the west but I would not make that
synonymous with the Christian world. Uh
the west has its own reasons for uh its
own real politique uh in the world and
it's I would say that it's nothing to do
with the Christian faith. uh for
example, the people of Iraq, both Muslim
and Christian, are continuing to suffer
under the United Nations sanctions which
are kept there, I believe, by the will
of the West. That's nothing to do with
Christian faith because there you have
the example of both uh Christian and
Muslim Iraqis suffering under the same
regime. So, I'd like to uh dispel this
myth that the West is Christian. uh
first of all and in Kosovo there that's
a basic question which is addressed by
the Christian faith in its appeal to
basic human rights for believers whether
they're Albanians in Kosovo or Bosnians
and so on and I agree that the um the
West and the United Nations in general
needs to take a much stronger line in
protecting the um ethnic Albanians
within Kosovo in giving them their human
rights and dignity within Serbia or
within whatever federation they move
into. And finally, a nice question from
someone which says this. After today's
conference, do you have any doubts about
being a Christian? And have you seen
that Islam is the only religion?
Thank you very much for this. I was uh
and always am impressed with the level
of knowledge of faith of the uh within
the Muslim community. Um and as always
my contact with Islam continues to make
me admire u it that faith Islam and its
adurance and yes I see constantly the
attractiveness of Islam and hope that
you can see the attractiveness of
Christianity also. So, thank you very
much for that and I'm sorry I have to
leave.
Thank you. Just to let you know what's
happening for the rest of the evening.
I'm going to ask Dr. Nick to speak for
10 minutes. He can answer one question
or 10 questions in that time, but that's
all he's got. 10 minutes.
Nine questions in 10 minutes is
difficult. I'll try my level best
inshallah. Is it okay for a husband to
demand respect from his wife and Islam?
Yes. But the Quran says as I said in my
talk in surah bakar 2 verse 187
that they are our garments and you are
our garments. Wives are the garments of
husbands and the husbands are the
garments of the wives. In the same way
even the husband should respect the
feeling and emotions of the wife. It's
both. Both should respect each other.
Can a brother marry more than one wife
even if he cannot afford to maintain one
in a reasonable standard?
The reasonable standard of each
individual differs. One individual may
say reasonable standard means I want at
least five bedroomedroom apartment. I
want a Mercedes car. The reasonable
standard differs what the Quran says in
surah nisa ch 4 verse number three that
marry woman of a choice in two threes
and fours. But if you can't do justice
marry one. The criteria is doing
justice.
If you have one Mercedes car and if you
feel the requirement is marry one more
sell the Mercedes car and buy two
Toyotaas car and give each wife one.
Sell the five-bedroom apartment and get
two-bedroom apartments and give each
wife one or keep both the wives in
five-bedroom apartment. The criteria is
equal justice. Reasonable standard
differs. That doesn't mean if you mean
reasonable standard means a particular
he should have a certain amount. That
means poor people cannot marry more than
one wife. That's not the criteria.
I'm sure the Muslims will agree that
only the acceptable to Allah is Islam
and that it is incorrect to say that no
religion is bad. I do agree. The Quran
says inah Imran chapter 3 verse number
19 in the loyal Islam the only religion
acceptable in the sight of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is Islam and I do
agree totally if anyone says no religion
is bad and stops there I don't agree
with him as a Muslim I don't agree with
him because Quran says in surah Iran 3
verse number 64
come to common terms as been us and you
what I would say that all religions
teach good things
because every religion religion teaches
good and bad things except Islam teaches
only good. So instead of saying no
religion is bad if you want to come to
common terms I would say all religion
teach good things first talk about the
good points between both the religions
and then come to the bad points what you
can say no religion teaches everything
bad that you can say but you can't only
say no religion is bad and stop that
trying to butter the other person
because Quran clearly states inah Iran
3:85 that no religion will be acceptable
on the side of Allah except Islam if
anyone demands any other religion
besides Islam it will never be
acceptable on him on the day of
judgment.
Is it true that Jesus will come back and
do Christians believe this?
Yes, we do agree the Quran says in surah
Isaiah chapter 4 verse 158 that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala raised him up alive.
So we agree he was raised up alive and
the reason that he was raised up alive
is why? Because Jesus peace be upon him
is the only messenger of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala whose followers mistook him
that he claimed divinity. They
misunderstood him that he claimed
divinity that he said he was God. So he
has been raised up not to teach anything
new. The Quran says in surah Maza
chapter 5 verse number three on this day
have I perfect religion for you and
chosen for you Islam and completed your
dean for you. Islam is complete. Nothing
new can be added. Nothing can be
subtracted. Isaam will not come to teach
anything new. He will come to tell the
Christians that I never said that I was
God. As the Quran says in surah Maida
chapter number 5 verse number 116, he
will tell to Allah subhanana wa tala.
Yeah Allah subhananaa tala you be my
witness. I never told them to worship me
but I said Abduah worship Allah who's my
Lord and your Lord. Similar message
given in the Bible on that day when
people will come and tell to Jesus peace
be upon him oh my lord oh my lord did we
not do wonders and miracles Jesus will
say you men of iniquity you depart from
here I don't even know you who will he
tell to the Muslims to the Hindus he'll
tell to the Christians that these sinful
people I don't even know you depart from
here he will come again to correct the
Christian not to bring any new teachings
please explain the advent mentioned of
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the Bible does the Bible prophesy the
event of prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the two questions seem
There are several prophecies of beloved
prophet Mosulus in the Bible. Old
testament as well as new testament. It's
mentioned in the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 18 verse number 18 that
God says I shall raise up a prophet from
among thy brethren like unto thee and I
shall put my words into his mouth and he
shall say all that I command him.
Christians say that this prophecy refers
to Jesus peace be upon him. But if you
analyze that Jesus was unlike Moses
peace be upon him. What they say that
see because Jesus was a Jew and he was a
prophet he was like Moses peace be upon
him. If these two are the only criteria
to fulfill the prophecy, then all the
prophets mentioned in the Bible after
Moses peace be upon him. Solomon,
Ezekiel, Isaiah, Daniel, Hosa, John, all
of them fulfilled the prophecy because
they were Jew and they were prophets of
God. If you analyze this prophecy fits,
it's no one but a beloved prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because both Moses and Muhammad peace be
upon him, they had an actual birth
unlike Jesus peace be upon him. Muhammad
and Moses peace be upon them both they
were married their children. and Jesus
peace be upon him did not have both of
them they died a natural death Jesus
peace be upon him he didn't die a
natural death according to the Quran he
was raised up alive in according to the
Bible but the false reading of
Christians they say that he was put on
the cross and there are more
similarities between Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and Musa Alisam is
Alisam and Mhammmed sallallahu alaihi
wasallam further it says from among
their brethren and we know that the
Arabs are brethren of the Jews again if
you read the book of Isaiah chapter
number 12 verse number 29 it says that a
prophet shall come who's not learned and
it will We said to him pray read this
and he will say I'm not learned. When
the first revelation came to our beloved
prophet Ikra surah ikra chapter 96 verse
number one when archangel Gabriel said
ikra our prophet said I'm not learned
exactly befitting the prophecy even the
name of the prophet is mentioned in the
old testament in the song of solomon
chapter number 5 verse number 16 in
Hebrew it is saidimi
muhamadim is added for respect in
themetic languages in the language
muhammad muhamadim is respect it's
actually muhammad with respect him it's
comedin but the translate as his mouth
is more sweet he's altogether lovely
he's my beloved he's my friend oh
daughter of Jerusalem but the original
manuscript contain the word of muhammad
in the old testament in the new
testament if you refer the gospel of
John chapter number 14 verse number 16
gospel of john chapter number 15 verse
number 26 it says about the coming of
the beloved prophet as a comforter it
said in the gospel of John chapter
number 16 verse number 7 that
nevertheless I tell you the truth it is
expedient for you that I go away for if
I go not away the comforter shall not
come for if I depart shall I send him?
The Christians say that this comforter
is the Holy Spirit. But the criteria
here is that the comforter shall come
only if Jesus Christ peace be upon
departs. I knew that the Holy Spirit was
already there in Elizabeth. It was there
when Jesus Christ peace be upon him was
born when he was being baptized. So this
prophecy cannot refer to the Holy
Spirit. It refers to our beloved prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Further if you read in the gospel of
John chapter number 16 verse number 12
to 14 it says I have many things to say
unto you but he cannot bear them now.
For when the spirit of truth shall come,
he shall guide you to all truths. All
the prophets prophesize the coming of
another prophet and the last and final
messenger, Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him except the last and final
messenger. And I have given a talk on
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam the
various world religious scriptures in
Hindu scriptures, Buddhist scriptures
and Pari scriptures, Jewish scriptures,
Christian scriptures. You can refer to
the cassette for details.
Is temporary marriage allowed in Islam?
Please. I know Muslims who believe in
it. Explain.
Okay, the time is up.
If you're referring to muta, it's not
allowed at all. Agreed. Previously, a
prophet didn't say it was wrong. He
didn't say it was yes because some
prohibitions came in stages like the
alcohol came in stages. Similarly, the
prophet didn't say anything. But in the
seventh hij during the tabuk expedition,
the prophet clearly state that mutah is
haram.
The other question if time permits
inshallah.
And thank you very much to all the
speakers and to everyone attending. Can
I just ask for a little bit of help as
you go out? Can you just stack some
chairs as you go out? Just uh two or
three at a time and it'll make the whole
job a lot easier for us. So just uh
thanks very much indeed. Is there a
father in this world who would not try
to provide for his children and his
wife?
Is there a father in this world who
would want to be locked up in a cell
away from his family? Is there a father
in this world who would not defend
justice and rights till the very end?